bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture de ce
mercredi 21 juin une émission 100% fête
de la musique à l'occasion de la 37e 35e
édition et durant treize minutes nous
irons à la rencontre de sol qui se
produiront sur scène et nous
rencontrerons notamment zéphirin groupe
yvelinois il ya un an remportée the
choice le tremplin musical de montigny
le bretonneux
le groupe pop-rock enregistre
actuellement son premier ep il danse et
fait danser les autres depuis 22 ans sur
saint quentin en yvelines
aulas ebe est le fondateur de la
compagnie illicites dance et aux
clayes-sous-bois à la musique se décline
en festivals celui des clés si belle le
samedi 24 juin ce sera la 23e édition
avec en tête d'affiche imany le groupe
est fier ils sont quatre et aime la
musique pop rock deux d'entre eux sont
originaires des yvelines et en 2016 il
remporte the church le tremplin musical
de montigny le bretonneux la ville dans
laquelle ils se produisent pour cette
fête de la musique
ils sont actuellement en train
d'enregistrer leur premier ep et nous
parle un peu plus d'eux au micro de
nicolas landry ses filles aînées en 2013
de la rencontre fait d'aurélien et deux
mois
on a très vite travailler ensemble sur
des compositions on a été rejoint
ensuite par valentin le guitariste et
valentin nous a fait rencontrer ensuite
thomas qui est arrivé pour assurer la
basse au sein de au sein des filières
[Musique]
m
on vient de différents projets chacun
différents projets musicaux et on a eu
envie de voilà de reconstituer
d'affaires de partir sur de nouvelles
bases
dans un style à la pop rock qu'on a
tenté ensuite de différents autres
styles musicaux plus groove avec
l'arrivée notamment de de thomas et de
valentin et c'est l envi voilà de créer
quelque chose tous ensemble à 4 et avec
une base musicale qui nous tient à coeur
et aussi des textes une écriture en
français se baser sur des compositions
ça aussi c'était tout l'enjeu du projet
zéphyr et de et ensuite de tourner deux
voilà de d'enregistrer de réaliser un
clip après par la suite qu'on voit là on
va faire un peu plus tard mais chacun
apporte son vécu son expérience et c'est
vraiment très très enrichissant ça nous
a permis de beaucoup évolué en
s'écoutant ans se comprenant aussi
musicalement et c'est vrai que ce que
tom apporte que valentin porte
qu'aurélien apporte
ben voilà c'est bénéfique pour le groupe
et pour l'unité qu'on a autour de zéphyr
parce que c'est une unité artistique il
ya aussi une unité humaine qui est là et
qui est très importante chez nous et ça
fait aussi le le ciment de du groupe
c'est ce qui nous permet d'avancer
ouais c'est vrai il a par le fait qu'on
s'aime beaucoup écart et qu'on s'entend
bien qu on a passé beaucoup de temps
ensemble
maintenant en tout notre richesse
musicale entre les années 70 jusqu'au
jusqu'à des choses très moderne beaucoup
plus même technoïde mais j'ai fait
d'improvisation aussi donc toute cette
richesse de recherche dans les
mouvements jazz ou aux américains cette
offre multi culturelle et puis ben
valentin gelé avec sa guitare électrique
tout le sens des années 70 c'est clair
et puis les influences aussi john
scofield vision des choses qui sont plus
plus structurée triturer au niveau du
son et puis deux
avec une base
toujours en dedans plus plus affranchis
plus plus pop geste est on ne peut plus
simple simplifiée pour parce que si on
jouait du jazz tordue on dit mais c'est
quoi ce truc là ça serait pas du
pop-rock sa large horizon sasaki gêné
j'espère qu'elles manquaient pas
résultats exacts
c'était une bonne expérience pour nous
on a voilà c'était il y avait des
groupes aussi qui était talentueux à nos
côtés nous on a eu plus
coup de coeur du jury coup de coeur
aussi du public ou pour nous ça a été
vraiment
m
belle récompense et puis ça nous a
poussés aussi à encore plus travailler
aller plus de l'avant et ça nous amène
aujourd'hui dans ce studio pour
enregistrer le p qui pour nous est une
étape très importante et donc voilà on
est très heureux dans le futur certains
de sept danseurs se produisent avec
beyoncé vita ou encore talent depuis 22
ans l'accompagné laisser des formes est
créé sur la ville nouvelle
nous avons rencontré son fondateur ho
l'afp sibylle regarder m ou 12 ans est
la nouvelle recrue d'illicite dance la
compagnie saint quentinois se fait
danser tous les âges depuis 1995 son
fondateur c'est lui aulas civi illicites
vraiment au départ donc il ya 22 ans
quand j'ai quitté black blanc beur et
que j'ai pris la décision de monter
cette structure mon objectif était
d'avoir une structure structure un peu
intermédiaire je trouvais que pour
arriver dans le milieu professionnel il
y avait un pas immense
on devait quitter la banlieue arrivée
sur paris connaître personne donc je me
suis dit je vais mettre une structure en
place qui va pouvoir former
professionnellement les jeunes les
jeunes qui ont envie de devenir
professionnel et leur apporter une vraie
rigueur une vraie discipline
[Musique]
sa femme est illicite c'est avant tout
une compagnie professionnelle
aujourd'hui sept danseurs la compose de
fou vivre son style au niveau national
et international
il ya une des chorégraphes qui
travaillent avec moi adeline qu'est la
chorégraphe de la compagnie
professionnelle qui a brillé sur
plusieurs plateaux télé et qui a été
aussi une danseuse sélectionnées pour
faire la publicité avec beyoncé pour
l'oréal il y avait trois danseuses de
suez à dîner et études donc une grande
fierté pour moi donc je me suis dit ma
petite formation dans l'ue elle n'est
pas si décalé que ça et puis après il y
en a eu d'autres ont gagné des concours
internationaux
après une pause d'un an la compagnie
repart sur les chemins de la création
son prochain projet le chorégraphie pour
la ryder cup la compétition
internationale de gauche qui aura lieu à
saint quentin en yvelines en septembre
2018 on reste à voisins le bretonneux
chaque année mais tu as as accueille des
groupes dans ses studios d'art d'une
expérience et l'un d'entre eux son style
de l'électro rock à l'origine de frais
rambolitains qui jouent ensemble depuis
dix ans la fête de la musique est leur
première fédéral entend justement je
pense c'est d'avoir réussi à mélanger
deux styles musicaux entre le rock qui
plus pour toi et l'autre côté l'électro
qui est plus actuel et bélanger
alors j'ai les deux styles mélanger les
deux styles donc moi qui vais jouer de
la guitare des sonorités un peu un peu
rock on va rajouter derrière de la
batterie d'aidés grosse caisse et de la
basse
vraiment électrique des sonorités
électro donc le mélange fait que c'est
plutôt pas mal
on vit des expériences nouvelles tous
les jours avec la musique
je trouve cela enrichissant de d'avancé
comme ça et de découvrir à chaque fois
de nouvelles choses et c'est ça qui nous
fait avancer dans la musique aussi
[Musique]
oui à druelle sauce bipôle we own the
night
oui
cameron
oprah diva s'articule eyes
[Musique]
là
à lui en cours la musique se fait comme
chaque année à la batterie la salle vous
accueille dès 18h pour assister à une
soirée concert jazz rock rap pop sont au
programme la musique sur saint quentin
en yvelines ce n'est pas seulement le 21
juin aux clayes-sous-bois le festival
des clés si belle revient ce samedi 24
juin ce sera ça 3 23e édition
sur scène des artistes locaux et
nationaux sept heures de concerts sont
annoncés
écoutez benjamin ball ans le directeur
du développement social et culturel de
la ville depuis les années 90 c'est
vraiment le rendez vous qui attendez que
les siens et bien au delà voilà toute
l'agglomération
c'est un rendez-vous qui qui accueille
au minimum dix mille personnes jusqu'à
15000 l'année dernière avec yannick noah
donc place est vraiment devenu un pour
une 23ème édition un rendez vous
incontournable
le but c'est vraiment d'accueillir à la
famille dans son ensemble puisque nous
faisons les portes dès l'après midi
donc c'est vraiment voilà les la
programmation est faite aussi pour qu'il
y en ait pour tous les goûts donc il
maniait la tête d'affiche mais manolo
voilà le chanteur des gipsy kings avec
avec un nouveau groupe vient donc c'est
aussi hyper familiale et puis toute la
commune ue nous recevons les groupes qui
ont été sélectionnés depuis deux ans qui
sont des groupes locaux des yvelines
voilà qui sont en progression pour
certains professionnels ou
semi-professionnels pour d'autres
amateurs voilà mais qui ont une qualité
puisqu'ils ont été élue et choisie par
un port un jury pendant deux ans donc
c'est voilà c'est rock pop rock reggae
voilà il ya vraiment tous les liens
vivier sur les clés sont mauvaises sur
le secteur pour ma passion j'ai dit oui
il ya des vies semaine sur
l'agglomération ce que nous avons
plusieurs studios de musique aux clés il
ya nos studios qui sont bien connus à
manille
voilà il ya différents lieux qui
permettent de faire émerger les groupes
de jeunes et de moins jeunes
c'est un enjeu pour la culture en
général c'est sûr que des finances
n'étant pas extensibles voilà pour
réaliser ce type d'événement surtout
c'est un c'est un festival gratuit dans
le bail est gratuite voilà ce qui est
rare dont on fait appel aux entreprises
voilà pour venir nous soutenir on a tout
un plan de mécénat voilà les tous les
dons sont acceptés duculty jusqu'aux
plus grands avec des contreparties en
termes de combien sur de communication
bien sûr de visibilité sur la
programmation voit des images des
différentes éditions il ya usage ya eu
jimmy cliff il ya eu yannick noah aussi
il ya deux ans sur la dernière édition
la précédente édition vous les fait
venir ils sont preneurs ils sont
partants c'est facile bah ça dépend ça
dépend là il m'a dit oui c'est elle a
entendu parler du festival et puis elle
sait que c'est que c'est un festival de
qualité où l'accueil est primordial
c'est aussi une ambiance voilà les clés
si belle c'est aussi un village musique
c'est vraiment une ambiance très festive
et puis je pense que le grand succès et
yannick noah aussi a fait parlé l'année
dernière
des fois il ya deux ans vous attendez
combien de général serais entre entre
10000 et 15000 personnes s'étant une
augmentation au fur et à mesure des
éditions alors tout dépend de la
programmation tout dépend du temps enfin
sur ces éléments extérieurs voilà c'est
toujours ça peut varier mais c'est
toujours un grand succès sur la
programmation on évoquait deux groupes
sur les autres alors mr yéyé collatéral
real crew voilà c'est vraiment on a on a
des univers très différents
voilà pour contenter tout le monde et
peut-être encore quelques surprises mais
c'est pas signer donc je peux pas en
dévoiler plus
et si vous êtes plus tentées pour une
star une séance de cinéma luc beaucoup
ont dû signer cette d'elancourt un film
à vous conseiller écouté le coup de
coeur cette semaine du 6 17 c'est le
très beau douzième long métrage j'ai
compté de cédric klapisch condamné à ce
qu'on apprécie beaucoup ici aussi 17 ce
qui nous lie donc c'est en fait
l'histoire de comment dirais-je d'un
frère qui est partie pendant 10 ans pour
fuir un peu son père qui fabrique du vin
donc ça se passe en bourgogne et revient
il retrouve sa soeur et son frère qui se
continue à s'occuper du domaine leur
père meurt et donc on va assister au fil
des saisons c'est filmé sur une année
sur les quatre saisons à la fois aux
retrouvailles de la fratrie est aussi à
comment dirais-je le fonctionnement des
vendanges etc etc
donc c'est à la fois un film très
intéressant sur le vin sur la façon de
fabrique du vin on parle vraiment de ça
dans le film est aussi sur les relations
entre deux frères et leur soeur c'est un
très beau film très émouvant
à découvrir dans nos salles cette
semaine papa consécutive du domaine
qu'on s'occupe de tout
et lui il est là il vit encore craqué
mais qu'est ce que tu connais ma
victoire lorsque l'on est d'accord je
connais rien d'elle résout jeu pour
médard
enfin je me dis que j'ai vu ce parti
pour fuir était revenu
quand le voyage mena
le monde c'est comme le vin c'est ton
lit
tout ça donne pas envie de rester la
toussaint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 7-8 culture est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]